yeah
happy friday everyone what a week huh
so let's look back at this mess
first let's assess the raid that the
cartoon owl had briefed us about
roll it sven
first
i personally approved the decision to
seek a search warrant in this matter
second the department does not take such
a decision lightly
where possible it is standard practice
to seek less intrusive means as an
alternative to a search and to narrowly
scope any search that is undertaken
third i will not stand by silently when
their integrity is unfairly attacked
the men and women of the fbi and the
justice department are dedicated
patriotic public servants
well he doesn't look guilty at all
i haven't seen a more sheepish face
since i woke up next to that ram
probably unnecessary
and he says they had to do it this way
because
well he never did say why
just that they had to do it this way
because they had to do it that way
that's what's called circular
and you need a circular saw to cut
through it yes honey i slept with that
stripper because i couldn't not sleep
with that stripper
as a
as a former stripper that makes no sense
and then he played the victim saying
that the fbi agents are patriotic
servants so lay off or they'll kidnap
gretchen whitmer
that edgar hoover would be proud of the
abusive power and the pension for
cross-dressing i mean why were they in
melania's closet
but let's face it i'm joking he is right
99.99
of them are patriotic servants but if
you were taking the servant part too
literally there's a fine line between
servants and yes men like the coveted
vaccines they're supposed to be better
and forgive us if we're a little wary
especially when you put threat tags on
angry parents at board meetings based on
a garland memo you know suddenly parents
became a terrorist group when the only
harmful thing they do is ask you to
friend them on facebook
you just say no
cause then they'll want more
but just like that democrats are
suddenly against criticizing law
enforcement they're putting targets on
the back
of fbi agents i don't have to suggest
that they are that they're planning
evidence don't call them
wolves you don't know anything going to
devour the american people republicans
have come out and condemned this said
this is banana republic kind of nonsense
demonizing law enforcement in the fbi
republicans who are as they complain
about the weaponization of the doj
and the fbi are in a way
weaponizing that rhetoric
they look miserable
i wish they were like this though during
the years of rioting and defunding when
the cops really needed them we were
there the whole time and we still are
but then they went charlie chaplin when
rioters torched cities when supreme
court justices were getting doxxed some
nut tried to murder brett kavanaugh
where was garland dozens of crisis
pregnancy centers are attacked and
garland has no leads ruth bader ginsburg
did more than garland and she's dead
and the press were so quiet on cnn you
could hear stelter's stomach growling
oh
it's so cute around feeding time
[Applause]
he can catch like a sardine in his mouth
but yes we criticize the fbi because we
criticize everyone it's the one thing i
have to credit the irs for we've been on
them since the late 1800s right back
when pelosi was just a high school
cheerleader
terrible
and biden had just received his aarp
card
but they never complained
the irs just assumed that's part of the
deal
same thing with lawyers and
chiropractors and dmv workers field goal
kickers and guys named chad
but sure complain to a fox news employee
about harsh criticism
do you see what we go through
i get more death threats than anyone and
only half of them i deserve
but this is just a ruse to silence you i
get it it's like when i told jesse
waters that mace was breath spray
fact is if you didn't criticize anything
for fear you'll trigger some nut bag
because you will
then we'd all be silenced
all heckling at sporting events must
stop we'd have to shut down real
housewives
it will become compulsory to say i love
the dmv
but the only people there's only the
only people you shouldn't criticize are
cooks at diners right
people who send back their meal hoping
it's going to come back better
[Applause]
never does
it never does unless you appreciate a
secret sauce
i'll leave it to your
imagination it's weird how the raid is
called an unprecedented action but then
it's called a search that's no big deal
how can that be joe scarborough actually
said that legal channels must be used to
go after angry people on cable news is
he so stupid that he forgets he's on
cable news
and corners the market in anger
yeah he is that stupid
at least biden has dementia what's his
excuse
if tv pundits who say outrageous things
are criminals say hello to bonnie and
clyde
but
why is uh
by his own reasoning he and the wife
should serve life sentences
although that would be cruel and unusual
punishment for the guards
so you notice there's a pattern to every
story involving trump or for that matter
anyone the media despises first the
story breaks and the facts are never
true trump says you should drink bleach
trump says there are fine people who are
nazis my god the border patrol are
whipping migrants
and then the freaks come out and say oh
the walls are closing in this looks like
it's worse than watergate and you know
this could be the thing that really
takes him down
and you know it's this this could be the
thing that really takes him down
i just look at him and i think turd but
but i'm not gonna say it
i'm not gonna say it good for you you
didn't say i didn't say it this time he
does not look like a turtle does not
look like a turtle even a little bit
exactly not even close
but then the truth comes out and it
isn't what the media wants so they turn
their angry gaze to you you become the
threat it's like when a crime is being
committed on the street the cop tackles
the bad guy he has to get physical to
subdue him but that's when the people
with the phones turn up now the crime
has that started it all isn't that
important anymore it's not the crime
anyway it's the backlash
they did this with russian collusion if
you were skeptical then you were a
traitor remember that not the people who
lied to frame the president they did
this with hunter's laptop if you talked
about it you were guilty of
misinformation not the people who
pretended it was fake to rig an election
that's the trend when the real story
defies media manipulation they make you
the story instead which is what happens
now
but hey it is still early i have no idea
what the hell's going on and what if it
turns out to be nothing what if it's not
really about nukes but something bland
like pages from dana's diary
then i fed the dog i put on my little
pony pajamas
i wrote a fan letter to garth brooks and
then i went to bed
not a bad life
so how bad would garland look now
i'd say he's making a mountain out of a
molehill but it's more like making a
tyrus out of a gutfeld
[Laughter]
seriously if they don't undercover
a homemade movie of donald banging every
member of minuto at a nuclear testing
site
this would be the biggest bust since cnn
plus
and it's hard to top cnn plus
[Music]
let's welcome tonight's guests
her smiles more electrifying than a
cattle prod in your bathtub fox and
friends first co-host carly shimkus
[Applause]
his videos are so viral they come with a
cdc warning packard comedian terence
kate william
the smirk from her on her face can be
seen from outer space fox news
contributor cat tip
you actually could walk a mile inside of
his shoes
pretty good my massive sidekick and the
nwa's world television champion tyrus
carly i want to break the illusion a
little bit this really isn't a live show
on a friday night we taped a little bit
early so there was some breaking news
they they released the uh uh what do you
call the um the warrants warrant yes and
the list yeah and as tyrus explained to
me
very very uh uh
eloquently it's like the album cover but
not the album does that make sense to
you right because you're talking about
what uh all legal experts and we're all
sort of learning this together is that
what everybody's really interested in is
the affidavit because that will tell
everybody what the judge was told and
why this judge finally approved the raid
but if we don't know that then we're
still all speculating as to why this
happened and i think it's it's a very
rare thing to say that
somebody's house gets raided by the fbi
and it turns out to be a good week for
them but that's sort of what this is
looking like there's still a lot we
don't know like you said greg you gotta
caveat it we don't we don't know a lot
legally but politically lara trump was
just talking about how donations are
pouring in in record numbers
i think that this is something that
could possibly motivate trump to
announce a presidency even before the
2022 midterm elections and this is
something that the left and some on the
right have never understood about him is
that
he you can't beat him at the political
game he
thrives during controversy and he also
represents people who feel targeted by
the establishment so this really does
fit into his wheelhouse perfectly well
he's an energy monster like if you he
just gobbles up energy so if you guys
you start flipping out that just makes
him even stronger it's very strange
terrence how you doing man i'm doing
good listen i want the fbi joe biden
nancy pelosi the democrats to know that
i'm voting for president donald j trump
in 2024. that's what i want them to know
okay you know
listen
what does that have to do though
congratulations on the applause
well you know what because this is more
listen this is not just about classified
documents right this is about stopping
donald trump from running in 2024 i see
they have nothing on trump yeah what's
next are they going to raid this house
because he didn't return a book to the
library
you know
he stole some white house napkins what's
next you know the the russia hoax didn't
work those phony impeachments didn't
work and then they said well this is
going to be the thing that takes him
down raiding his home and going through
melania's closet is going to take him
down not the russia hoax not the
impeachments but this this is the one
man
it's ridiculous it is it does feel like
the one worry too is that they took all
these boxes
so they if they don't find what they
said they were finding they might find
something they could charge but why are
they just now looking for these
classified documents yeah yeah he's been
out of office for over a year now why
are they just now looking yeah and if
it's nuclear stuff tyrus i do you think
that they would take they wouldn't be
taking their time well well well greg as
you know i'm i'm real tight with brett
bear who yeah
he's on vacation and did he have the
message from brett
i actually have uh
the actual articles on the affidavit of
things that they were looking for that
they actually found he gave him to you
and not to catch not to cat no for some
reason apparently
his
he doesn't have as good as a humor
yes yes well i had nothing to lose what
am i going to do yeah oh the white house
lawnmower uh there was
[Laughter]
all the toilet paper keys to the bowling
room
and uh looks like abraham lincoln's hats
you they got him
what if what if i kind of looted this on
the five what if trump actually did
break the law but he didn't know he did
because trump with trump became
president he had no clue what would like
what
all this stuff is like hey can we uh can
we go we go to mexico and bomb mexican
drug dealers which actually is a great
idea but no you can't go bomb a country
but still it's a great idea he probably
said who i do like lincoln's hat there's
a lot of them here yeah
listen when you stay in a nice hotel
room and there's a really nice robe yes
you're like this is a nice road yes
well it's kennedy's robe well it's my
robe now
[Laughter]
so i i'm willing to bet it's more of
that yeah he didn't take bill clinton's
rope because it was very stiff
disgusting
disgusting
disgusting that you would applaud that
it's a test to see how wholesome our
audience is this one has flunk
filthy filthy filthy filthy people it's
true though it's kind of the way what
part
this list i've been to the white house i
went to the white house when trump was
in there and i got a nice tour there is
really no it's not that impressive it's
kind of dingy really yeah it's very
dingy it's old it's very old and dingy
unlike you cat yeah
well i've never been to the white house
so i'm not going to comment on the
interior design of it with you
hypothetically if you were at the
would you steal anything look again like
we all have all been saying i just feel
like there's so much that we don't know
at this point so i'm not going to sit
and pretend that i know what i think
when i really don't because the more
that comes out the more questions that i
have and i have questions that i've
never even like haven't even heard
people talking about like what are
nuclear documents yes
i googled it i was like what are nuclear
documents and it was like documents
relating to nuclear weapons like what
are we talking about is it like a piece
of paper that's like how to do a bomb
right like is that
i just think that's a really big deal a
piece of paper with a code yeah exactly
maybe that's just like exactly i'm just
i don't i didn't know there were nuclear
documents are there really pieces of
paper floating around out there about
how to do a bomb
is that what it is so honestly i think
especially because obviously this has
not been the first time that people say
we got them we got them i think even
some of my friends who are on the left
have privately told me that they would
love to see him go to prison but they
aren't sure that this is it because even
they are questioning isn't it because
it's happened so many times i'm going to
wait and see he's not even in power
anymore right so it shows you that even
when he was in power it wasn't about him
being president it was about trying to
get him in it's like it is when you i've
never seen
such an emotional investment
in somebody i mean i find it i find it
funny i find trump funny i understand
why he drives people crazy but i also
step like you can step out of it and you
can go like i see why he makes people
crazy because i have friends who are
crazy they don't even talk to me right
thank god but anyway but you can see the
effect but but at the same time when you
see the effect it it disarms the
psychology of it but they can't do it
it's it's uh it's such a strange thing
and they're they're replaying it again
right now on television and they're not
even aware of it very strange they are
obsessed with them obsessed and i'm
obsessed with you
[Laughter]
i don't know
seemed like the right thing to say
don't go to hr hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else